les vietnamiens vivent au rythme de deux
plantes le riz nourricier et le bambou
aux multiples vertus
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu plusieurs fois des accidents
soit le bambou se casse est tombée du
mauvais côté
ou alors quand on le coup le bon bout se
fissure il devient très tranchant
alors là il faut faire attention de ne
pas marcher dessus
parce que ça devient coupant comme des
lames de rasoir
la province de thanh wa abrite la plus
grande forêt de bambous du sud est
asiatique
une réserve inépuisable
les bambous atteignent 8 mètres de haut
en à peine trois ans
coupé du bambou est un travail très
fatigant mais c'est notre seule
ressource pour survivre
on entre dans la forêt on court et on
doit transporter tout ce bambou au bord
de la rivière l'aide est lourd mais moi
les mâts de bambou sont portés sur plus
d'un kilomètre
celui-là pèse entre 35 et 38 kg j'ai mal
à l'épaule
il faut faire attention la pente est
très glissante
[Applaudissements]
la coupe et le transport rapporte aux
hommes un euro par jour
les plus courageux multiplie par dix ce
salaire en acceptant la seconde partie
du travail
le montage d'un gigantesque meccano
un radeau peut contenir 500 à 600 tiges
de bambou
on est obligé de passer par le fleuve
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
l'assemblage se fait sans clou ni cordes
c'est bien trop cher
[Applaudissements]
tu n'es pas assez solide il manque une
couche
[Musique]
paternelle pour que leur ado arrive à
destination il faut que l'accord soit
solide
si le courant est trop fort et qu'il est
mal attachés on pourra plus le maîtriser
[Applaudissements]
il y a un an le courant était tellement
fort qu une fois on a perdu un radeau
entier
un bon rat d'eau doit être souple et
surtout étroit afin d'offrir le minimum
de résistance au courant
le géant mesure près de 50 mètres
le radeau est tellement grand qu'il
faudra anticiper les virages longtemps à
l avance
sinon on risque de s'échouer sur le
rivage
le gouvernail nous sera utile
[Applaudissements]
leur radeau n'est pas vraiment un modèle
de maniabilité
bateau ivre dirigé par des capitaines
embrumé de tabac locales
les virages s'annonce épique
[Musique]
il faut reconnaître que c'est un voyage
dangereux
en général à chaque départ
on a des craintes et ça jusqu'à
l'arrivée
[Musique]
on a de la chance
les conditions météo sont bonnes
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
30 km et 5 heures de descente ballotté
au gré de l'humeur des flots attendent
les hommes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le radeau glisse sur les pierres
il faut faire attention
à
force de taper dans les rochers les
liens de bambou se desserrent leur ado
risque de se disloquer
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon père qui m'a appris à naviguer
sur cette rivière
[Musique]
dès que j'ai su nager
je suivais mon père et mes oncles
ils m'ont tout appris
il n'y a pas d'école pour ça
parfois je transporte jusqu'à 800
[Musique]
le luong rivière capricieuse referme peu
à peu ses pièges sur l'équipage
le passage de la caverne du fantôme leur
promet quelques sueurs froides qui
le radeau de bambou se trouve en terrain
calme
les hommes en profitent pour le
renforcer la grotte du fantôme n'est
plus très loin
après tout ce qu'il a subi on va lui
refaire une petite beauté qu'il soit
présentable pour la livraison
[Applaudissements]
c'est important de resserrer les tiges
de bambou pour que leur ado reste bien
solide
les coupeur de bambou appartiennent le
plus souvent à l'ethnie hmong
alliés des français puis des américains
dans les deux guerres qui ont secoué le
vietnam les mangues en paye encore les
conséquences
les métiers les plus pénibles leur sont
réservées
il y à d'autres métiers
mais pour les ethnies minoritaires comme
nous les hmong il n'y a que le vent vous
car ici l'exploitation du bois est
interdite
seul le bambou de la rivière luong est
autorisé à peu faire une multitude de
produits grâce aux bambous c'est grâce à
lui que l'on peut vivre
fin du temps calme les rapide entraîne
de nouveau lors à dos dans une course
folle
la partie qui nous attend maintenant est
vraiment difficile
parce que c'est un grand virage
faire tourner un radeau de près de 50
mètres de long est loin d'être chose
facile
on sont les hommes aperçoivent la
fameuse grotte du fantôme et son virage
tant redoutée
cette fois ci le fantôme de la grotte a
été clément
à leur dernier passage le radeau c'était
explosé contre la paroi
et les bonbons s'était répandu dans le
fleuve
[Musique]
une fois sur le fleuve songhua les
hommes sont relayés dans leurs efforts
par un bateau à moteur
[Musique]
cette berge signaux la fin du voyage
l'ensemble des radeaux représente à peu
près 3000 bon goût
c'est ce que l'on doit livrer aux
patrons ce sont des grossistes ils nous
achètent moment vous et les revendre aux
usines
pour nous le travail est terminé
maintenant nous allons rentrer chez nous